Cyclone Citroen battled in from the Bay
of Bengal early Tuesday with winds
gusting up to 88 kilometer per hour and
the storm surge of about 3 meters
heavy winds with rain and storm surge
damaged thousands of homes in the
coastal region and flooding low-lying
coastal areas
yesterday during the storm and heavy
rain the part of our house got all
inundated there was a strong wind and
many trees also fell and we couldn't
even venture out and were very scared
the Cyclone brought rains and flooding
in other parts of the country including
the capital Dhaka
due to the storm and rain we are
struggling a lot as all the streets are
indeed by floods so it's very difficult
to drive our Treasures
the Cyclone originated in the Bay of
Bengal before turning north towards
Coastal Bangladesh
and massive massive equation saved life
during cyclone cyclotron that slammed
the coastal areas of Bangladesh
electricity Supply Telecom and Road
communication were severely disrupted in
many regions
hundreds of electric poles were damaged
or Tilted due to the storm and some were
totally destroyed electric lines are now
disrupted but we're working to restore
them within a few days
Bangladesh's government says it is
assessing the physical and financial
damage
due to the Cyclone around 10 000 homes 6
000 hectares of cropland and a thousand
hectares of fish hatcheries were damaged
aside from the coastal areas the storm
has also hit other regions of country
also
Bangladesh is situated in one of the
world's largest Deltas making it prone
to natural disasters scientists say
climate change is making Cyclones and
floods more intense and frequent making
Bangladesh among the 10 most vulnerable
country
most people who live in coastal belts
are poor subsistent farmers and
fishermen for many of them there's
little left of their belongings and
homes to come back to tanvi chaudry Al
Jazeera Kali Bangladesh